hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about the various
characteristics that all living things
have so the characteristics of life the
first one is that all living things are
made of cells you may hear this
described as all living things are
cellular and there are two types of
cellularity there are organisms that are
unicellular we often think of bacteria
as being the major unicellular life
forms but there are also used
unicellular archaea and unicellular
eukaryotes there are also many forms of
life that are multicellular meaning made
of multiple cells animals for example
are multicellular and in particular in
multicellular organisms we have
something known as specialization that
is cells that are specialized for
different functions within the
multicellular organism if we use human
beings as an example human beings have
brain cells blood cells heart cells
kidney cells skin cells eye cells lung
cells etc many many different types of
cells that all have specialized
functions that contribute to the overall
health and functioning of the
multicellular organism characteristic
number two is that living things are
able to reproduce and there are two
types of reproduction there is a sexual
reproduction where the daughter organism
is genetically identical to the parent
organism this is called clone bacteria
reproduce asexually specifically through
a process known as binary fission if
you're interested in learning more about
how bacteria divide and about this
process of binary fission please see my
video on that topic
there's also sexual reproduction this is
how animals reproduce
as well as many other types of organisms
so for example this is when a gamete
from one organism and acad from another
organism meet for example when a sperm
fertilizes an egg and the offspring is
genetically different from both parents
because the offspring has genetic
information from both parents
so that is sexual reproduction the next
thing that distinguishes living
organisms is the use of DNA or genetic
information information in living cells
follows a certain path it is stored in
DNA it is then sent through RNA to make
proteins and so this movement of genetic
information from DNA to RNA to proteins
is an important concept in biology it's
actually known as the central dogma of
molecular biology and if you're
interested in learning more about the
central dogma please see my video on
that topic I do want to mention one
exception there are viruses that use DNA
as their genetic information but there
are also viruses that can use RNA as
their genetic information
however viruses are not considered
living things they're considered to be
intracellular obligate parasites they're
basically like little molecular machines
made of just a bit of protein and a bit
of either RNA or DNA so they are not
alive and thus we can still say that DNA
as the genetic information is a
characteristic of all living things
another characteristic is the use of a
universal genetic code and the fact that
the genetic code is universal is an
important piece of evidence in the fact
that all life evolved from the same
common ancestor in the universal genetic
code there is a language and in this
language the words are
basically codons so the codons are
series of three nucleotides that code
for an amino acid so remember that
nucleotides make up DNA and RNA amino
acids make up proteins and so with this
universal genetic code the nucleotides
in RNA code for specific amino acids in
proteins so for example the codon Aug or
adenine uracil guanine all these codes
from a thiamine so whenever there is
this codon in RNA the protein that has
made incorporates a methionine in its
place and so this genetic code is used
by all living organisms living organisms
can also grow and they can develop and
these may sound like the same thing but
really there are some important
differences growth refers to increasing
in size either because the cell itself
grows in size or because the organism is
acquiring new cells through mitosis and
so you're getting an overall change in
size of the organism development refers
to a change in shape or most importantly
a change in function and it's the
development process that leads to
specialization that is as organisms
develop their different cells when
they're multicellular organisms can
acquire different types of
specialization leading to an overall
develop organisms another characteristic
of living things is their ability to
adapt to their environment
this occurs to something known as
natural selection this is because in any
population there are individuals who
have different genetic signatures
different types of genes different
mutations and some of these may be more
or less favorable depending on the
environment and so over time this allows
populations to evolve so natural
selection leads to evolution of
populations it's important for you to
understand that individuals do not
involve individuals are either more or
less suited to their environment based
on their genes those that are more
suited to their environment are more
likely to survive which makes them more
likely to reproduce which makes them
more likely to pass on their genes to
the next generation this means that over
time populations can evolve as favorable
traits become a larger part of the
population and unfavorable traits are
selected against so that is the ability
of organisms to adapt to their
environment at the level of populations
the next characteristic of living things
is their ability to use energy energy is
defined as the ability to do work
organisms have to do all kinds of work
that they need energy for individual
cells have to be able to signal to each
other they have to be able to take
nutrients in they have to be able to
expel waste products and at the multi
cellular level organisms have to be able
to do all kinds of work they have to be
able to find food they have to be able
to make shelter they have to be able to
outrun predators they have to be able to
grow and develop these are all things
that require energy and how do cells get
energy well it's through the process of
metabolism and specifically through
cellular respiration which generates
something called ATP
ATP stands for adenosine triphosphate
it's often called the energy currency of
the cell this molecule is how the cells
release energy that is stored in
chemical bonds for the cells use when
it's needed if you are interested in
learning more about aerobic respiration
during the ATP is made please see my
video on that topic the next
characteristic of living things is their
ability to respond to the environment
for example phototropism is when plants
grow towards light a reflex part is when
you touch something sharp or touch
something hot and the signal doesn't
even have to make it to your brain
before you're pulling your hand away
these are both examples of responding to
the present environment and this is
something that living things can do
unicellular organisms can do it too for
example bacteria can display something
known as chemo tropism this is when they
can move towards chemicals that would be
used as nutrients or they can move away
from chemicals that might be harmful so
it is the attraction to these chemicals
known as chemo tropism and the movement
toward or away from these chemicals
known as chemo taxes these are both
examples of how unicellular organisms
respond to their current environment and
finally the last characteristic of
living things we're going to talk about
is their ability to maintain homeostasis
homeostasis is kind of a big word that
simply means the physiological
steady-state conditions for example
unicellular organisms they want to
maintain their tonicity inside their
cells versus the external environment
and they have ways to do this that
involve bringing solutes in or bringing
water in or sending solutes out whatever
is needed to make sure they have the
proper tonicity examples in
multicellular organisms include things
like thermal regulation thermal
regulation is a way that organisms
maintain their body temperature as
needed for their specific type of
metabolism so for example things like
shivering and sweating are things that
help to maintain the body temperature to
help maintain the physiological steady
state that the organism needs to be
healthy and functional another example
is something like the excretory system
the excretory system is what helps to
expel wastes from animal bodies without
being able to expel waste they would
build up in the body to be very
unfavorable very unhealthy for animals
so the excretory system helps to get rid
of those wastes unicellular organisms as
well have different types of ways to get
rid of wastes for example things like
exocytosis or even different types of
channel proteins that allow things that
are no longer needed to be expelled from
the cell so here you have it the various
characteristics of living things I hope
you learned a lot and thanks for
watching biology professor